la chloroquine les études se suivent et
ne se ressemblent pas suite à une étude
très critique publié par le land 7
vendredi l' oms indique ce soir avoir
suspendu temporairement les essais
cliniques avec ce médicament qu'elle
mène avec ses partenaires dans plusieurs
pays par mesure de précaution en france
le ministre de la santé eau vive et
rangs devant lui une révision des règles
de prescription
alors cette molécule est elle oui ou non
dangereuses face au co vite ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes en direct
avec violaine dire un immunologiste
collective kovy 19 blessés sont les
médecins à prescrire bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour en débattre avec vous
laurent alexandre médecin essayiste
bonsoir à vous également laurent
alexandre
alors avant de vous donner la parole je
voudrais qu'on écoute didier raoul teint
qui s'est donc exprimé comme tous les
lundis sur sa fameuse chaîne youtube de
lits h une méditerranée voilà ce qu'il
dit concernant cette étude de l'insee
parue vendredi
si vous ai passé quatre mille malades
dans les mains croyez pas que je vais
changer parce qu'il ya des gens qui font
du big data qu une seule espèce de
fantaisie complètement délirante qui
prend des données dont on connaît pas la
qualité qui mélange tout qui mélange des
traitements dont on ne sait pas quelle
est la dose qu'on a donné 6 e se
prenaient des articles auxquels on peut
se suicider avec un sur le 30 ans prend
trop comme avec le doliprane a été
vraiment en réalité plus d'un joueur qui
doit aussi toit ou qu'ils se promenaient
regardez c'est la première cause
d'intoxications dans les pays modernes
du monde
c'est dangereux avec cet humour donc si
vous voulez comment voulez-vous que une
étude foireuse fait avec les big data
change ce que nous avons
alors voilà on étude est foireuse un
manque de sérieux selon didier rahout du
coup laurent alexandre est ce qu'elle
permet vraiment de répondre
notre question ce médicament est il oui
ou non dangereux non l'étude du lancet
été très intéressante et c'est un
message d' alerte qui doit nous
inquiéter et nous rendre prudents mais
ça n'est pas une étude prospective
randomisée c'est une étude rétrospective
donc ça nous donne des signaux des
signaux d'alert nous devons faire
particulièrement attention en attendant
que les essai prospectif randomisé
arrive mais nous ne pouvons pas ce soir
affirmé que la potion du professeur
raoul tu augmentes la mortalité
on ne peut pas l'affirmer à partir des
données que nous avons pour l'affirmer
il faudrait des essais cliniques
randomisés qui vont arriver alors je
pense pas seulement à discovery et puis
à rick overy mais également l'étude qui
a été lancé par le n aie est chaud aux
états unis à l'instigation de son
directeur adjoint qui est le professeur
fossile donc les données de l'étude du
lancet d' sont inquiétantes il y a pas
mal d'études
on pourrait même dire une avalanche de
données inquiétantes récemment les
données du british medical journal ne
sont pas bonnes non plus qui doivent
nous inciter à la prudence
mais il n'est pas possible d'affirmer ce
soir que le protocole du processeur à
ault tue davantage que le placebo
on ne peut pas dire ça ce soir mais
certains craignent certains le craignent
suffisamment pour que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé est interrompu son
nez c'est enfin la partie de son essai
qui concerne hydroxy chloroquine pour
vérifier qu'on n'observe pas avec un
comité spécial qui va regarder quel est
l'état de la mortalité chez les gens qui
sont sous hydroxy chloroquine dans
l'essai qui est organisée sous l'égide
de de l'om est donc ce soir on peut pas
affirmer que ça tue le protocole raul tu
mais certains le craignent notamment
l'om est donc il faut être super prudent
et je pense qu'il faut maintenant que
les médecins aient conscience du fait
que on a pas mal d'un 10 en défaveur du
protocole raul tu es qu'il faut faire
attention
alors bien sûr à ou peut-être plus
excessifs il a dit beaucoup de mal cet
après-midi de tout le monde des revues
scientifiques
du big data on va en parler laurent alex
l'emportement l'emporteront out ne doit
pas cacher le fait que nous avons en ce
moment une avalanche de signaux négatifs
sur son protocole donc prudence prudence
prudence
oui effectivement verront vous voulez
pas connu pour interne ardent défenseur
du protocole de l'idée round auront
apprécié l'honnêteté ce soir ça ne
prouve pas que ça tu es vous l'avez bien
souligné laurent alexandre law oms
indique avoir suspendu temporairement
les essais cliniques avec ce médicament
violaine guérin ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous regrettez justement
toutes ces études très critique qu'il
faut que voilà on arrête des essais qui
pourrait peut-être conduire à de bons
résultats qui c est sauver des vies en
tout cas je vous pose la question en
pleine guerre
merci beaucoup de me donner la parole
donc je précise que je suis médecin et
qui est suivi des patients atteints par
locaux vides
donc j'ai une expérience de terrain et
j'aimerais bien que les personnes qui
prennent la parole et tout suivi des
patients à la fois en phase précoce qui
est la phase du traitement sur laquelle
le professeur raoul tu a insisté qu'il
était important de travailler en phase
précoce pour éviter des complications
pour éviter des passages justement en
hospitalisation et également pour
diminuer la contagiosité puisque l'idée
est de diminuer la charge virale donc ça
c'est un premier point
l'étude dont vous parlez elle est
extrêmement étonnante d'abord parce
qu'elle a été faite sur une base de
données de cardiologues
quand on regarde les groupes et que l'on
compare le groupe contrôle et le groupe
des patients qui ont été traités eh bien
on s'aperçoit déjà que sur plus de 12 à
remettre les groupes ne sont pas
comparables à la base et que le groupe
des patients traités est beaucoup plus
grave
alors comme on est sur une base de
données cardiologique c'est pas
tellement étonnant puisque on sait qu'il
faut être prudent lorsqu'on presserait
d'eads roxy chloroquine et la
chloroquine et là tu es trop micinn à
des patients qui ont des problèmes
cardio à la base
donc si on regarde bien
population à qui cela était proposé en
plus dans le monde entier avec des
techniques de soins qui sont différentes
selon les pays
et bien cette étude finalement elle ne
fait que confirmer une chose c'est que
quand on ne respecte pas bien mais
contre indication de les drogues cyclos
qui n'est qu'on l'a prescrit à des gens
qui ont des pathologies cardiaques
graves
oui c'est dangereux alors après je suis
extrêmement étonné d attitude à la fois
de l'eau oms est de même de notre
ministre de la santé qui en plus notre
ministre de la santé a restreint usage
de la coquine avec plusieurs décrets
successifs précisément chez les malades
graves sous oxygénothérapie donc là il
ya un forte embarras sur le sujet après
ce dont je peux vous témoigner c'est que
le protocole initiée par le professeur
raoul tu as été testé en france par des
médecins a été testé dans beaucoup de
pays du monde et avec succès en phase
précoce je rappelle parce
qu'effectivement quand on utilise des
drogues si chloroquine chez des patients
qui sont fragiles qui ont peut-être
aussi des atteintes cardiologique du
virus et bien cela n'est pas forcément
une bonne chose
et dans cette étude par exemple on n'a
aucune idée du nombre de patients qui
ont eu des scanners est ce qu on a fait
attention si ces patients avaient des
mets aux quarts vide dépérit qu'invite
demio péricardite parce qu'aujourd'hui
on sait justement que ce sont ce type
d'atteinte avec les atteintes
pulmonaires qui conduit yves à des décès
ou à des séquelles aussi parce que c'est
cela qu'on est en train d'observer
aujourd'hui donc je comprend un petit
peu même si je ne connais pas du tout le
professeur raoul tu qui est un peu en
colère contre ses études
ce d'autant plus que
on a quand même trois études de son
équipe qui ont certes en particulier
pour la première des critiques mais des
méthodologies qu'avant recevoir bien sûr
mais je pense qu'il ya d'autres études
également qui ont conforté dans le monde
les résultats de l'équipe du professeur
raoul qu il ya des pays et on le voit
les pays qui ont prescrit ce qu'ils ont
préconisé son protocole sans forcément
faire les études puisque comme on est un
peu en temps de guerre quelque part des
pays ont donné l'aval pour ce protocole
et on voit très bien que qu'il ya moins
de décès et comme des choses se sont
mieux classés et autres lois
fondamentales oui oui sous tour on va on
va laisser aussi parce que c'est un
débat effectivement que vous voulez
c'est échanger tous les deux on a évoqué
la question du big data
laurent alexandre le professeur ou qui
critique également les big data en gros
il dit voilà moi je fais de l'humain je
compile pas des données vous êtes un
spécialiste d'ailleurs laurent alexandre
de l'intelligence artificielle vous
comprenez quand même le désarroi de ce
professeur qui effectivement c'est une
cible pour beaucoup et cet argument qui
fait ma voilà moi je ne complique pas
des données je fais de l'humain
l'expérience on va parvenir à la
médecine de 1950 à la médecine de
molière on est en 2020 on fait de
l'avastine avec des dossiers médicaux
électroniques avec du big data avec de
l'intelligence artificielle
je ne pense pas que les français
souhaitent qu'on revienne au temps des
robes août le autant des médecins de
molière des saignées des clis terre donc
oui la médecine de 2020 un professeur
raoul qu elle se fait avec du big data
elle se fait avec des bases de données
avec de la rigueur scientifique
moi ce qui m'inquiète dans la ville
monsieur rend ton cas on sauve des vies
la chloroquine ne tuez pas générer des
ombres le professeur raoul qu'il
approuvait qui sauvait 0 vie ces études
sont méthodologiquement bonnes pour la
poubelle
elles ont des billets qui sont
inacceptables et son grand allié le
professeur peron dont l'étude a été
félicité par monsieur raoul tu et par
madame guérin a été retiré en
catastrophe il y a trois jours si vous
avez twitté deux fois sur cette étude
est exact de vos tweets madame
ne veut pas ça ne veut pas dire que
cette étude cette étude a été retiré en
catastrophe pour problèmes
méthodologiques
donc voyez le problème c'est qu'on a
dans le clan des rats ou c'est à dire
les études sur défaite à marseille
les études faites par le passeur période
ont des faillites des faiblesses
méthodologiques absolument épouvantable
qui doivent nous nous faire être
extrêmement prudent nous ne pouvons pas
prendre de risques avec les patients
pour l'instant on ne voit pas les effets
positifs de ce protocole
en revanche sur l'emploi laisse effets
négatifs si vous savez si loin ms
interrompu son essai c'est pas parce
qu'il ya un complot mondial contre le
professeur raoul tu comme certains de
ses fans le pense c'est parce qu'il ya
un vrai doute imaginer qu'on généralise
et qu'on donne à tout le monde
ce protocole alors qu'il augmenterait
significativement la mortalité non
aujourd'hui il faut faire attention
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure et on
peut pas m'accuser d'être sectaire
l'étude du lancet ne permet pas de
trancher définitivement ce sont d essai
randomisé prospectif qui le permettront
mais ces données sont suffisamment
inquiétante pour qu'on fasse attention
il ne faudrait pas qu'on découvre dans
un mois qu'on a tué l'un d'eux malades
avec un médicament qui tuerait davantage
que le placebo qui tuerait davantage que
l'absence de traitement il faut qu'on
soit très vigilant
personnellement je pense que l'om est sa
raison il est important de regarder
pendant les données qui ont déjà été
comptait que collectés dans l'essai
solidarité il est important de vérifier
que ce protocole n'augmente pas la
mortalité des malades parce que notre
but a non médecins ce n'est pas
d'augmenter la mortalité avec des
médicaments
c'est l'abbé c'est donc il faut que nous
soyons certains que ce protocole
n'augmente pas la mortalité et moi très
franchement je vous lance ce soir on
laissait l'étude du lancet tu ne me
permet pas de trancher ne nous permet
pas de nous médecins deux tranches est
gelée dite raisonnée tout cas la
dernière me suis mis c'est quand même
oui c'est comme un signal d'alarmé
ils vont faire attendre au moins je
n'exclus plus ce soir que le protocole
raul tu augmentes la mortalité chez les
malades
et vous imaginez la gravité si cette
crainte issues de l'étude du lancet tech
firme est donc soyons très prudent et le
fan club de raul tu dois faire de
meilleures études parce que on en
parlait il ya deux minutes quand on voit
qu'il a fallu retirer en catastrophe
l'étude du professeur peron qui pourtant
a été à auray à prouver et apprécié par
out on se dit qu'il faut faire attention
et qu'il faut faire de la science de la
vraie science de la science
d'aujourd'hui en s'aidant du big data
contrairement à ce que pense raul parce
qu'on est au siècle de l'informatique
est pas aussi avec le des médecins de
molière
violaine guérin le mot de la fin on peut
tuer quand même avec ce médicament c'est
un argument qu'il faut entendre tout de
même ce sera le mot de la fin rapidement
s'il vous plaît oui c'est tombé ce que
je puisse pas parler plus soudé que je
vous ai laissé la parole mais pas trop
trop long parce que vous avez des
dérives laisse assez longue tous les
deux les français apprécient je pense la
médecine de qualité qui est une médecine
on est ausculté les malades et est une
médecine ont fait du big data et je
pense que monsieur alexandre qui a des
logiciels à vendre peut-être parle
plutôt de cela on a du mal à comprendre
qu'on prend on n'entend pas par exemple
l'accès de l'agronome à ce qu on entend
par exemple quand même répondre lors
alexandre on va voler le téléphone et
madame et c'est malhonnête des
diffamatoire quand on a la parole en
dernier
non non non justement justement laurent
alexandre avez vous dit que j'allais
vous donner la parole en voir où on va
on va couper la peau jours à partir de
dimanche soir
on va vous laisser répondre on va
laisser finir violaine guérin sur son
idée et on vous donnera le mot de la fin
laurent alexandre pour vous puissiez
répondre
allez je pense que le point fondamental
c'est de laisser des médecins à
prescrire de décider avec leurs patients
et ce qui est tout à fait à les financer
cette guerre et quand j'entends monsieur
alexandre parler de potions raul tous
deux par les deux camps raul tout autre
les médecins ont simplement envie d'être
tranquille et de prescrire et pour finir
je voudrais dire
il est inadmissible de ne pas entendre
par exemple que l'équipe du professeur
raoul tu as fait plus de dix mille
électrocardiogramme à des patients qui
ont été suivies qu'il n'y a pas eu de
complication majeure ce que nous
également sur le terrain nous avons
observé dans les drogues si chloroquine
est prescrite dans le respect de ses
contre indications et nous avons demandé
à la nfl les données justement de
pharmacovigilance de 2017 2018 2019 qui
montre que globalement il n'y a pas
d'effets indésirables sur cette molécule
qui est connu depuis plus de 40 ans et
qui a été prescrite qu'il n'avait pas
besoin d'être prescrite puisqu'elle
était hors ordonnance jusqu'au 15
janvier 2020 donc ça ça veut aussi dire
quelque chose et d'autre part on a tous
ces patients qui sont traités par
hydroxy chloroquine qui sont qui ont des
maladies qui sont graves parfois avec
des atteintes cardiaques comme des lupus
ou d'autres maladies comme la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde et qu' on n'a
jamais eu toute cette grande guerre pour
prescrire ce médicament
donc je suis extrêmement inquiète de ce
qui se passe parce que en aidant de
l'irrationnel et je pense pour moi en
tant que médecin de base on va dire
laissons nous tranquilles laissons-nous
travailler et on sait faire ça depuis
extrêmement longtemps et cette molécule
autres plein de gens aussi en ont eu
pour partir en afrique ou ailleurs
elle n'a jamais vraiment eu et grande
voix là et on va à donner le mot de la
fin très rapidement s'il vous plaît à
laurent alexandre parce qu'on est arrivé
large et je vais juste dire que le
procédé dégueulasse qui est de dire que
les gens sont vendus quand ils ne sont
pas favorables à l'hydroxyde rocklyn
c'est vraiment très moche je jure sur
l'honneur de n'avoir aucun conflit
d'intérêts dans cette affaire
je n'ai pas de logiciels à vendre
contrairement à ce que dit madame guérin
de façon parfaitement dégueulasse et je
n'ai d'intérêt ni en faveur de la
chloroquine ni en saveurs des
concurrents de la chloroquine et tout le
discours du clan à ould qui de dire que
les gens qui sont dans votre route
so vendu à gilles ead est dégueulasse en
tout cas moi je jure sur l'honneur que
je n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts madame
ce que vous avez dit et diffamatoires
et c'est vraiment dégueulasse merci en
tout cas le droit de réponse laurent
alexandre et violaine guéret remercie
d'avoir accepté le débat